[Music]
and we're back yes this is episode 22
right 13 o'clock episode 20 22 we're
going to we're going to do one called
The Devil's breath yeah yeah I first
heard about The Devil's breath
off of ice yeah that's probably where
most people heard about this concise did
a very bit of very like well-known
documentary probably but glow in the
2007 I want to thank you doesn't 8 yeah
it was a while back yeah I grew up in
Brazil and I'd never heard of the devil
stress I was kind of surprised yeah I
grew up with some Paulo Brazil and you
know I had friends from across the
spectrum down at the street level and
rich friends and the ones at the street
level you know I'm surprised I thought I
would have heard of this drug but I
guess they don't use it in Brazil yeah
but it scared the crap out of me well
some of the stories about it are very
good especially the ones that were on
Vice and what we kind of wanted to do
with this show is sort of try and sort
out the you know the reality acrimony
legend now you know nobody knows exactly
but it seems like there's a lot of
stories about this drug that seem like
they're kind of exaggerated I'm not
saying that it's not a scary drug
because it is what The Devil's breath
supposedly does does it turns you into a
basically a zombie where you will do
whatever a person says and not remember
it when it wears off and you don't NT
you don't show any signs of being
drugged you seem totally lucid you'll
this you'll get dosed with it they'll
say let's go to your place you're going
to give us all your stuff you'll even
help them load up truck and get all the
ice with all your [ __ ] you'll empty out
your whole apartment and you'll even go
up to the doorman said oh no it's okay
I'm moving you know and then it wears
off you're like man my house is empty
where's Ali [ __ ] yeah and I saw that and
I was going like man that that's a
really dangerous [ __ ] there is that true
and I was thinking that can't that can't
really be true because
if it's a drug with that power powerful
you think the CIA be using it right so
the thing about this drug it has a very
long and complicated history now the
main bone of contention and why it made
such a big impact was specifically that
because it was supposedly one very easy
to administer you could just blow it in
people's faces or hand somebody a piece
of paper or business cards or just wipe
their face or didn't wipe their face
with it or hands can be a business card
or piece of paper that had been
saturated with it yes and immediately
these people would be totally compliant
they would do whatever you said some
some people even reported it just the
smell of it was enough to get you to
become compliant yeah but man I know so
we had we went in did an investigation
yeah and that's kind of the most
controversial aspect of it yes I think
we should probably talk about the
network though than you and you have
something you wanted to say about the
network oh well we just wanted to remind
everybody that the project entertainment
network on which our audio version is
hosted they still have a patreon on the
YouTube video put a link but other than
that just go to patreon.com/scishow okay
Matt networks throw them a couple bucks
they have some cool swag t-shirts you
know postcards from the different
podcast and whatnot that you can get if
you give a couple of dollars so you know
just do that plug that yeah I also
wanted to plug that Ginny has a really
cool book coming out and probably next
couple months or use it right yeah yeah
it'll it'll be out like the early part
of this year yeah there's no other book
like this it's it's basically an
encyclopedia of all the poltergeists
reports going all the way back from
probably what 500 AD yeah something like
that bill is one sound it's like 100 and
something cases right yeah it's gonna be
really good it's not good not a
collection of ghost stories these are
actual classic poltergeist type cases
you know we're talking about you know
along the lines of you know Kerry and
you know basically you know the
firestarter this is when you say well it
was a little bit different in it yeah I
mean I have a whole chapter in there on
fire starting colder guys I have a
chapter and row stone-throwing fault or
hit on it but like I said it's just
pretty much every well-known story and a
few obscure ones you know going back to
like the fifth or sixth century you know
as far back as they've been reported and
I kind of you know go into like a little
summary of each case so I try to get as
many cases as in there and then the end
of the book is going to be kind of like
a general pair of psychological
perspective on you culture Geist
activity so you friend of that kind of
stuff the books going to be called the
unseen hand it's also going to have a
subtitle but I haven't figured out what
it's going to be yet but it'll probably
be out in a couple of months it'll
probably be two months it's going to be
really good I don't think there's been a
book like this written not for a while
anyway no not for a while yes okay uh uh
I guess we can go ahead and start with a
double breath there yeah so we're
talking about The Devil's breath it has
actually goes under many names and I
first heard of it I didn't realize it
was the same plant until we started
doing the research for this podcast now
when I was in now this must have been
probably I guess I was still in high
school but left in the late 80s and I
remember that there were these news
stories going around that there was a
teen trend you know how [ __ ] news and
there was always teen trends they were
always doing something really and most
of it was [ __ ] I'm sure yeah but uh
you know but how I first heard of its
alcohol Animas and things like that
oh my god you're doing alcohol we're put
out we're putting tampons in vodka so
you have been sticking them up our
bottom where like who's doing that like
no one's doing that come on love it
who we do that I don't know but so
here's the thing so there there were
some news stories going around when I
was a kid that people were taking the
flowers of what we call angels trumpet
because we don't I don't think they grow
wild in Florida but a lot of people do
have them ornamentally because the
flowers are very pretty
like so a lot of people have those trees
in their yards and I actually I think a
neighbor of ours had a tree with angel
trumpet on it but um apparently these
teens those crazy teens they were
picking the flowers and infusing them
like into a tea and drinking it as a
hallucinogen now not that I hung out
with a bunch of druggies I hung out with
some druggies but what I did not know
anybody that did die and honestly like
after I found out this is the same drug
and stuff like that the drug that comes
from this flower
like very very few people use it
recreationally because the high is so
unpleasant it's a bad true because the
effects or so unpleasant is it like a
lot of people are not using it they're
called scopolamine scopolamine is the
main alkaloids are on this flower and it
comes from what they call it it grows
wild in Colombia and it's actually
called the drunken binge tree that's
been there and it's it's actually it's
related to deadly nightshade
henbane it definitely is poisonous no
one's saying that although it does have
some legitimate medical uses yeah now
scopolamine it's also known as hyah seen
it was actually isolated by a German
scientist in 1880s always some Germans
coming up these weird drug I don't know
what that I didn't come up with it okay
just you know discovered that that was
the compound that was causing these
effects and I'm gonna blame the German
okay I was a German everything if the
Germans fault yes in German yeah just
kidding we love you German yeah but um
so he isolated in about 1880 now its
first use was actually to induced labor
or to you know kind of take away the
pain of Labor now evidently the doctor
that discovered it he noticed that when
he gave it to women in labor that they
would start telling the truth or
something it's like I'm not really sure
like how did you know it was the truth
not asking them some some pretty spicy
questions and they're they're fast
enough maybe maybe that's what it was he
didn't really specify man need the babe
love this one hahahahaha so then they
started thinking well maybe it would
work as a truth serum right so it
actually was experimented with as a
truth serum in the 20s and 30s and I
think later on I think the kind of those
communist government in Czechoslovakia
was using it as a truth serum
you had to get people to confess the
crimes that they didn't commit yeah I
even think that the
Q's Joseph mango Mangala as used in his
youth but a doesn't default well it's
unsurprising understand could be true it
was just rumored I don't pay my glove
with interested in coppola lien probably
not but the problem with it as a truth
serum which I think even as then I think
this is even on the CIA website that
American police in the CIA experiment it
was a little bit so they did admit it
but the problem with it is that it's
also a hallucinogen so you don't really
know if what they're telling you is true
or people are just making [ __ ] up you
know what I mean so like I said I think
I mentioned before it actually does have
legitimate medical uses see cygnus and
stuff like yeah like if you've ever
learned real small doses yeah if you've
ever worn one of those patches to keep
you from getting motion sickness or
sickness that's what's in there at
scopolamine it's a low dose and it's
also used to treat Parkinson's disease
anti-nausea like how some people get
sick from anesthesia like surgery
they'll give it to you to keep you from
getting sick so it does have some
legitimate medical uses however in high
doses it is some nasty ass [ __ ] okay and
it will actually kill you
the bone of contention is whether it
takes your freewill away yeah does it
make you a zombie it make you a zombie I
mean I didn't even said that
Mesoamericans you know like the Maya yes
they would give tripoli
scopolamine to human sacrifices or like
when a king died his wives and his
consorts all were giving scopolamine and
they would walk down into a tomb and be
buried alive right that's like what
would make them more compliant yeah or
it would make you yeah willingly lay
there and get your heart cut out that
kind of thing right you know but and if
that's what that's a serious claim yeah
could you really give somebody
scopolamine and tell them to lay here
why we cut your heart out all right yeah
I don't know I I kind of doubt it I
think that if if a drug were that
powerful it would be far more popular
especially with intelligence agencies
you capture a guy and you give them that
use it as a truth serum
or use it to to execute a political
enemy
yeah they drive your car into this wall
you know yeah you think they'd be using
it everywhere yeah you would think so
now the main the main use for it
and I don't think this is in any dispute
most of the cases that are reported of
criminal gangs using it which is pretty
much the only people use it cause like I
said recreationally it's not fun so most
people don't take it recreationally in
Colombia Ecuador places like that which
is where the tree grows wild evidently
there are whole criminal gangs down
there to call it burundanga video it's
also called Devil's breath it called
angels trumpet up here at the flower but
it's the same it's the same plant
so these criminal gangs will synthesize
the [ __ ] into a powder it looks like
cocaine and they will give it to women
and race them or they will give it to
men and rob them so I don't think that
that's in dispute that does happen like
these gangs like that you know God will
be at a brothel you know he'll be
approached by a prostitute she will put
some of the scopolamine in his drink and
then you know he won't remember anything
like she'll give she'll take all his
money and leave him on a park bench
somewhere and no one will remember what
happened they want to give him some
tales let's give him some Street legends
about this okay now some stories now on
the Vice documentary they actually
talked to a few people that apparently
had been victims of this particular drug
there was one guy on there who he went
to it was a brothel or a nightclub or
something like that and he was
approached by two women he was partying
there with his friend or whatever and
evidently the women put scopolamine in
his drink and then he started to forget
things now he woke up the next day or
whatever it was on a park bench beaten
he was beaten up and he found that most
of his money are all of his Olly was
gone had been taken out of his bank
account all his credit cards were gone
on all of his wall gone everything was
done and he didn't really remember what
had happened to him so then now
apparently there was footage of him
taking his money out of the ATM yeah
and he said that the girls that were
with him were with him but they were out
of the out of the camera right what they
were off camera right yes so like I said
he appeared to be taking his money out
really willingly but he says he doesn't
remember doing that
of course he was super drunk as well
Rochus he had been drinking all night
with the girls so god this tank is loud
yeah well I know Rajee Navin
it's an RDA you know they're loud that's
okay yeah everybody knows what they make
water vapor we had to open the door
because I was afraid and set the smoke
alarm off it's still mine oh yeah that
has happened I can make enough paper to
actually set a smoke alarm Oh that'd be
a start down on when I find her that
would be funny I think I'd leave it in
show - well yeah Carter everybody
laughing happy where the comments is
anything what do you do I don't know and
I like some of the vapors like hey what
what do you liquids do you like didn't I
should have said no you weren't vaping
it's like now he's just start no yeah
and that's just my respirator yeah he's
there fader but I get nervous I started
apron
yeah well I'm getting off topic off top
that's okay all right so anyway so and
you know they also had the Vice
documented also had a prostitute they
interviewed her and she said that she
willingly admitted that she used it all
the time yes to steal money from her
John's to steal things from various
people now she said that she
administered it by putting it like
smearing it on paper and then smearing
on people's noses yeah she said she did
it to an old lady and she had a heart
attack yeah but I didn't really believe
her
I'm not sure yeah I'm not up in Brazil
you understand that you know that the
culture there especially kind of at the
street level they like they like to
grandstand they like to tell stories you
know and they'll they'll uh they'll
exaggerate a lot this is you know it's
kind of like a sign of their power you
know I mean so I don't know how I think
it's lies a lot of an exaggeration
so I mean that's why it's so hard to
kind of get to the bottom of it because
the drug is actually dangerous and it
does have particular effects but I don't
know if it's quite escaped because
here's the thing it's like Vice might
have kind of started it off by call it
the world's scariest drug and there were
all these kind of big deal articles
about it and like I said it just kind of
reminded me of back in the old days when
they were talking about oh these kids in
the rickety a tangle trumpets and
they're getting they're getting high off
it or whatever and it does seem like
it's kind of maybe some exaggeration
there yeah you know they had a drug
dealer telling the story about friend
Ezra got dosed with it that kind of rang
true with me we said he had real high
tolerance towards drugs so he got dosed
with it and it didn't affect him so they
kept dosing him until eventually he just
died yeah and it never really he never
really yielded to it right you know he
had to give him a lethal dose to give it
effect so that maybe that might account
for some of the inconsistencies in these
stories
yeah that's under some people report
remembering what they did and other
people report that they can't remember
anything yes because the one girl that
they interviewed um she was apparently
given it by a stranger he you know he
was asking for directions or whatever
and she like took him somewhere and he
bought her some juice or something and
she drank it and apparently was doped to
it
now she claims but she's like I happily
went to my apartment and handed over all
my money and all this other kind of
stuff but she apparently remembers doing
that yeah but see the strange thing
about it is that the drug itself it does
cause memory loss yeah it's but it's
like a date-rape drug it's like a roofie
you know it will make you not remember
ship it happen to you so you'll wake up
the next day and go what the [ __ ] that I
do you know what I mean
but the weird thing is that some people
stories about it they do kind of
remember at it so I don't know if some
of these stories are kind of exaggerated
or kind of or if people's physiology
just means that maybe they kind of do
remember some [ __ ] they do
I was like oh I did this on a why I did
that or something like that they could
be let's try to tease it apart so and
making things more complicated too is
that there are stories about the drugs
that are pretty much certainly urban
legends back in 2013 there were a lot of
urban legends going around and you know
the turned up usually it happened in
Texas or Missouri that a man yeah what
the man is I'm aware employment vasa it
was Texas man though I guess if it's not
if it's not Florida's usually Texas or
Arizona yes and we live in Florida we
know all about Florida man yeah Florida
man would you already know about fourth
year people are unlucky I haven't turned
up this Florida man oh you will want to
know sure okay but so there were some
stories going around that there were
gangs in the US that apparently were
saturating business cards with
scopolamine and then you know the story
would go a lady went to a gas station
and she was at the pump and this guy
came up to her and said oh I have a
painting business if you ever need any
painting he handed her a business card
and then he gets in a car and then she
gets back in her car and starts driving
and she notices that these guys are
following her in a car and then she
starts to feel super funny and she dizzy
and everything like that and in the
urban legend nothing bad happens to her
she just pulls into a driveway and says
hey I feel like [ __ ] and then the guys
drive off but you know the the legend is
that the paper was saturated with
scopolamine right and if that smell of
it got to her and just touching it with
them right now see but the problem with
that is that a lot of medical
professionals or people or talk to
colleges or people who study this kind
of thing say that you can't get that bad
of a dose just by touching something
that's been soaked in it yeah so here is
kind of where a lot of the controversy
arises because one of the big things
apparently in Colombia and actually this
happened in Paris as well there was a
case in Paris a couple years ago where
apparently this criminal gang was two
Chinese women and another
guy whose race they didn't say well I
think they said it was a Chinese crime
syndicate I think that's the wrong been
shiny alright it okay so they were
apparently going around blowing miss
stuff into the faces of old people
and then when they kind of resolve out
they would take all their [ __ ] alright
but I'm not super sure like if that was
suitable I mean if they were positive
that that's what it was apparently they
did it a bunch of times before they
caught him and they said at that point
was right but I'm not sure I'm going
that in those stories were they going to
be ATMs and and cleaning themselves out
as zombies like here I'm going to give
you all my money
here yeah I'll enter my pin number yeah
not happening with enlightened
consciousness and they were just taking
their purses what was right yeah see
that's the thing
I'm not real sure like if the reports
didn't really say what they were yeah
they said they were robbed yeah other
money okay you know some of them may
have been taken to an ATM but see that's
the thing where where that's why I kind
of want to do the subject because
there's so much missing leg ndon out it
right because like I said anything even
like a lot of alcohol is roofies
anything like that I've been I've been
dosed at a nightclub before okay I don't
know what it was I don't know if it was
rohypnol I don't know if it was GHB or
whatever but you know what what happened
in my experience was I was there I was
on my first drink I don't even think I
finished my first drink and then all of
a sudden I was like I'm really sleepy
and I passed out yeah I just hit the
floor I had to be carried out of the
club you were married at the time yeah
so my husband not there yeah yeah yeah
this was this was a long time ago and um
I was there with my ex-husband and a
friend of ours and so they had to carry
me out there to put me in the car and
then you know on the way home like an
hour later I woke up and I was vomiting
all over myself
but I didn't do anything I was just
asleep I was unconscious
and there was the booth what they saw
the booths and headed okay
Oh cruel it is yeah mean not he so means
it's all fun again yeah okay so like I
said I don't know this stuff scopolamine
will knock you out it will make you lose
consciousness it will kill you if you
have a high enough dose yeah the
question is will it make you walk around
like a normal person and do whatever
anybody wants you to do after somebody
just blows it in your finger that's the
legend is it true that's what I mean I
don't know because I don't know it's
just blowing it's um I mean I feel like
and some other toxicologists and said
this online you would pretty much have
to ingest it or like snort it up your
nose for that to have any effect I mean
if somebody blew it in your face and
your mouth was wide open and you have
swallowed a bunch of it maybe yeah but
it's blowing it on somebody or just
swiping it on someone's skin I don't see
that that would be potent enough yeah
because there's in the vice documentary
there's a young prostitute
she's what 21 22 yeah and she just said
that all she had to do was wipe it
across somebody's face yeah that's what
she was saying or shan't leave enough to
turn them into a zombie and in one case
she wiped it across an old lady's face
in an attempt to rob her and she fell
over dead I think it's only just a chat
a heart that she said she benighted
died right and that's I'm trying to
analyze her you know because I
understand smash I speak Portuguese
fluently it's very close and I know
South American culture and I think she
was grandstanding I think she might have
been yeah and she could she was also
trying to get a little bit of a pity
party for her about how hard her life
was yeah I wasn't totally buying what
she was saying I don't think that's
enough because the guys that because
guys that I'd be lead you know their
stories of dosent people they said they
had to put in people's drinks yeah yeah
which you know where I had to put it in
a cigarette and had to smoke it yeah
what's that's totally believable
wrong because
I said I've been doing before or but in
a drink and it knocked me the [ __ ] out
and in that same documentary there's a
funny drug dealer a street-level drug
dealer the guy's hilarious that guy
seems super fun oh yeah yeah yeah
hilarious
he goes into the bicycle follow me and
when he comes back he's totally coked
out and he's all aware if you haven't
seen it you as you go totally cooked
it's worth it just for that guy he opens
up the little package of Cibola mean
alright because you smell it you smell
it oh yeah we got to ventilate the car
we get rossignol get high you know what
we get we'll all be zombies and then he
goes on I don't worry it's not enough
it's not enough
yeah so you're kind of seeing its
legendary effects hey just smelling it
enough but then he goes no I don't worry
if not enough yeah so he said it was
airborne
yeah airborne now and I saw it right
what helped you guys right there you see
you see kind of like the the street
legend yeah
the chest smelling it is enough yeah but
then he backs off of that now I don't
worry it's not enough yeah and you can
see how that [ __ ] kind of happened right
you're scared of it they're scared of it
so much of where they're handling it
like it's lutonium or [ __ ] anthrax
yeah the Hun he said I need that he said
what I did I'd like an answer
it's worse than a dress and I'm like I
don't know how long what's the truth
yeah you know what's the truth well a
second part of the show we'll try to get
down more truth okay well you want to
take a break now since we're like about
a half but okay so we're going to take a
break we'll be back in just a few
minutes watch out there's a new terror
taking over kitchens around the world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast brimming with
recipes tips food five
seasonal specials and guests galore
hosted by horror author Amber Fallon hey
that's me a foodie was over 20 years of
experience cooking baking and generally
making a nuisance of herself
you watched Food Network you've read
cookbooks but nothing can prepare you
for it cook coming to a device near you
subculture corsets and clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets comm set subculture
corsets comm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets comm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 ladies and
gentlemen Radek Entertainment Network
presents along the mentor is the
greatest manager of all time
Markham known of becoming superstar good
words anything I'm not going to get
you'll mean I'm not going to teach you
three standard check out a right hook he
used to love it it's like a cordless ok
I see your eyes will be on track
Entertainment Network
[Music]
[Music]
there are terrors real and imaginary and
I write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction Rossdale desires
the Mammoth Mountain culture yet so
stable monster read minute supply of
Rosella weather go to WWJ AFRICOM or
search Amazon for the Jenny Ashford
cocker page and Rebecca yes talking
about the devil's breath The Devil's
breath the world's most dangerous drug
yeah
scare is drug in the world yeah it's
that we're going to cut your we're going
to give this to you and you'll climb up
to the top of an Aztec temple and we
will cut your heart out and you'll love
it
awesome let's do that drug it's that
drug is it true see I don't know that's
where that's where what we should know
because we've done the research well I
know but see the expert stuff now leave
the experts on them like I said there's
because there's so much missing legend
built up around this and because that
there is truth at the bottom of it like
ice kit like I said scopolamine which
comes from this flower is a very
powerful substance it will make you
unconscious it will make you not
remember [ __ ] you know it will make you
hallucinate yeah if taken in the right
dose does it make you a zombie though
and here's where and actually this is
funny because we were we had some
friends over last night and they were
asking what our topic was today so we
were talking to them about it and our
friends and mitri said exactly the same
thing that I was thinking that this
whole blowing [ __ ] in their face to turn
people into zombies I was like Serpent
and the rainbow yeah and so I'm
wondering if people are conflating those
two things because honestly you know I'm
sure most of you are familiar serpent
the rainbow was based you know the movie
was a horror movie but it was based on
the anthropological studies of Wade
Davis I thought when I was a kid in high
school yeah I didn't like it oh I did
yeah a lot people liked it I thought
it's a guy friends liked it I watched it
like a man
we saw there's this how about it didn't
become like any no I like stuff just
that that movie didn't do that for me I
like it
but the movie was obviously highly
exaggerated but it is based on real
research that this guy did however you
know yes there is a powder that's
pointed us like that it comes from the
blood comes from a Blowfish and it's
mixed with other things but in that
movie it was the same kind of thing like
these you know Rue du doctor you know
witch doctor whatever you call them they
were nice yeah they were in her presence
kind of witch doctor and I went apart
there but in the movie they were going
around blowing this powder in people's
faces and it was putting them into that
weird catatonic kind of state so I don't
know if people are conflating the
scopolamine thing with the serpent the
rainbow thing which was actually
fictional right that now that zombie
drug that they use the Blowfish poison
that is a neurotoxin and it can cause
catalepsy but as in this case I don't
think that you can get a high enough
dose just blowing it as somebody right
because so much of it like diffuses out
into the air you wouldn't really get
much but you know what I mean it's not
like it can just land on your skin
you're like oh man I'm [ __ ] up right
but I don't think the dosage would be
high enough you would have to give it to
somebody they would have to drink it or
snort it well do we have another legend
or at least a story about it that we can
tell the audience of exactly what
happened to a person well or are they
all just too big that's what I mean it
seems like most of the stories that were
in the Vice documentary were kind of
vague stories I noticed that too and you
know the one girl they were talking to
these girls at the beginning like in a
restaurant and she was like oh my uncle
was a cab driver yeah and somebody gave
him scopolamine but really all that
happened in that story was he died right
and I'm like so she didn't really know
that any details about it and not never
said it he became a zombie present that
and honestly really there were only one
or two things in there where people
actually said oh I there was proof that
I actually somebody saw me doing stuff
like helping these criminals clean my
house out or really bad things or
whatever so is it possible like I said
it does the drug can make you such asses
have and suggestible
they said it affected your amygdala
gasps and with it which is that it
controls your aggression and
fight-or-flight response what price
right probably suppresses that so you
don't want to fight back yeah is one of
the things that happened but the
question is would it make you do
something that you wouldn't normally do
if you had all your faculties of
euphoria from not that I ever saw okay I
mean really like I said if it caused any
kind of euphoria then people would take
it for fun and apparently no one does
that
okay I mean even in Colombia where it
grows wild and even though they were
talking to this drug dealer and pretty
much everyone they talked to you down
there it's like why would you take that
for fun we have coke we have weed like
this [ __ ] is no fun it may run violently
ill it's always a bad trip it lasts for
a long time the trip can last for a day
or two
Brooke you know like several days and
it's not pleasant so they said no one
really does it for fun there's a lower
your inhibitions not so much I mean that
might be something to do with it but
like I said a lot of things do alcohol
does that right I mean yeah and you
might do dumb [ __ ] I'll call they
wouldn't do when you were sober but I
mean how drunk would you have to be for
somebody to go hey give me all your
money out of the ATM and you go sure all
right yeah you know I don't I don't know
some people might I don't know you see
me drunk I remember everything that
happened yeah so so I don't really know
like I said maybe some people are just
naturally more suggestible than others
yeah and so maybe it works like that on
them right but maybe if you were more a
more strong-willed person it would one
real
to work on you because you'd be like nah
I'm not gonna do that well that one drug
dealer said that they just did it to his
brother wasn't it NZ brother yeah and
then it just killed his brother yeah cuz
he was either his brother his friend I
can't remember I think it was this
roommate as a ruminator the roommate so
they just kept giving it to him and it
didn't didn't have any effect on him
into it Fila killed him
because if if this drug was could really
do that and could really do it reliable
reliably then you'd think that [ __ ]
terrorist organisations all of the place
would know I can use it simply recognize
it yeah of course
so so I don't know where the truth lies
and really it seems like almost all of
the stories about it come from Colombia
or Ecuador right um couple stories like
I said there was one that came out in
the paper in France I think that was
2013-2014 about a gang that were doing
that to old people and I think there
have been maybe a story in Thailand
Vietnam something like that but there
haven't really been any confirmed cases
in the US have been happening there's
been some urban legend and like I said
there was an urban legend when I was a
kid about you know kids making it into
tea but like I said I didn't really know
anybody that was doing that and it's
funny we were talking about this one and
I said this might be a kind of thing
where I don't remember a few guys one of
our very early shows probably the second
one that we did about the satanic panic
and I said I think the media coverage of
The Devil's breath is kind of along
those same lines where you know just
like in a satanic panic you know are
there creepy serial killers out there
that maybe we'll draw a pentagram or
something yes it does happen you know is
there an organized cabal of these people
going around you know sacrificing babies
knows it no yeah using women as breeders
right so I feel like this might be that
same kind of situation where you know in
scopolamine dangerous yes our our gangs
using it yes our gang doing it yes they
do use it they put it people drinks it
to rob them to rape them whatever you
know does but the thing is I
I don't know I don't even know if
there's a you know a distinction to be
made
it's bad enough like getting dose of the
drink and then waking up and all your
[ __ ] is gone
or finding out you've been sexually
assaulted you know but the question is
whether you were complicit in your own
victimization right that's what the lie
guess is this that's why it made such a
big impact and like violence is so scary
not just that you've been rendered
unconscious and people are doing
horrible [ __ ] to you and you don't
remember it from but that you were going
along with it right and I think that's
probably why people are afraid of it
right and the funny thing is in the vice
documentary the two guys like and I
actually read an interview with the one
of the guys that that would went down
there and he said that before they did
the documentary like he was all jazzed
he's like yeah I'm going to try this
[ __ ] I would give it to my friends and
make him do all kind of stupid [ __ ] I'll
be hilarious and then when he got down
there and started hearing all the
stories about it they actually score if
you see the doctor they actually stored
some and they put their little their
little face masks on and that till it
and they're open it all carefully like
it's going to blow up or Jay and I may
end up just kind of flushing it down the
toilet pointing out he got they
chickened out yeah because he's like oh
you know I heard all these stories and
suddenly it wasn't funny anymore like
I'm like I don't know it could still be
fine
it's like giving it to your friends and
be like you didn't do that come on
Abby's terrible you can put it on
YouTube but I think that's kind of what
he was thinking when he went down there
but then when he actually got down there
he's like oh maybe there's Easter Bunny
but uh because it might actually kill
you it might actually make you do all
these horrible things that you don't
want to do but like I said it's cut it's
kind of like I don't know and I feel
like the media doesn't help because it's
kind of like you know they're they're
having all these headline world scary
strong zombie draw of LSN stuff and I
feel like that's not helping because in
a way and I think like I said I said
this on the satanic panic show too and I
thought about this one that when the
news was going off of that angels
trumpet and all these teams AET out of
it I said you know what probably no one
was doing it before
but now they are because you talked
about it
yeah or Lisa like it's like they're
making a trend I was something that
wasn't one yeah that's like old school
quick bait I didn't yeah I know a lot of
guys that were drinking you know when we
were young we just drink our asses off
did I'm doing they weren't doing alcohol
enemas no I don't know a single per day
were made data that did that know that
seemed like that went around like
probably a couple years ago I realized
it was possible and they just wrote a
story about it yeah or even like one guy
did that's the thing one guy did it like
yeah you know what I bet somebody
thought I'm like jackass or something
yeah and then that you know somebody did
it and then suddenly you know one guy
does it and then suddenly the news picks
it up and it's a wacky story so suddenly
it's a trend everyone's doing it and
like I said the more the news brings it
up
well yes people are going to try then oh
they think oh let's all do this that
sounds like a cool idea you know I mean
as far as devil Devil's breath goes
based on everything I could find about
it and everything I've heard about it
the testimony I think basically all it
is is it's something similar to like a
roofie yes uh it's not going to be
reliable some people are going to have a
high tolerance and resistance to it
other people will be roofied and they'll
be robbed and they may go along with it
to a certain extent but it's just
because they're passes and maybe they've
also they've also been kind of affected
by the propaganda oh oh yeah and that's
kind of gets back to what I was just
saying is that sometimes the media makes
the story it's like it's you know like a
snake eating its own tail could be that
someone comes under the effect of it
Nazy or they go man I've been hit by The
Devil's breath I'm gonna do whatever
they say
yeah and they just kind of go that's how
it works and they are any you know
intoxicated so they just you know yeah
they fall victim to it's almost kind of
like a voodoo curse mixed with the drug
and I do do curses only work with you if
you believe if you believe them and they
do work right because you know it's just
like the placebo effect yeah like a
placebo yeah the weird thing about the
Fecteau it's like you would think that
it only works if you don't know you're
being given a placebo no even if you
know it's a placebo incident right
it's kind of the same thing where if you
tell somebody look LSD makes you go
crazy yeah you will lose your mind and
you will you'll never be normal again
and then you give somebody LSD and if
they the fear and that the fear of the
LSD and then expecting to lose their
mind they'll have a really bad trip yeah
yeah that's why they're not is that why
it's very important if we're going to do
LSD go into a positive some - otherwise
you're gonna have a big trouble just
don't do drugs kids are bad but I think
that I think that's that's a big factor
of it it might be the legend behind
devil's bread maybe that wise is
affecting the people who get dose with
it because it does seem like I mean
because it came to the attention of ice
and everything like that I mean
apparently there is a lot of street
legends about it yeah so like you said
it might it might be like a feedback
live where people are getting dosed with
it and then expecting right well I think
if you were to dose somebody with Devils
breath in the in evidently the proper
way to dose somebody would just put it
in in in a drinking and directed by Tom
entered in a cigarette yeah I'll just
wipe in the face and blow on powder I
don't buy it
even if you if you were to dose somebody
in the US with that and this person has
no idea what Devil's breath is it's not
part of the culture I guarantee you they
would just get sick yeah they were just
getting sick or they would just fall
asleep for our fall asleep or lose
consciousness it'd be something like
that yeah because we don't really have
you know well other than the vice
documentary on cultural if there's no
cultural expectation of how it's going
to make you behave and like I said I
don't think it would be any different
now it might make it might make you
flaccid yeah but other drugs do that job
to do that alcohol can do that it
wouldn't be it wouldn't wouldn't be any
different than being roofies right so
like I said I think the problem with it
is not that it not that it doesn't do
what it's purported to do because it
does you know they know that chemical
they know what effects it has but one
everyone's physiology is different
everyone's ex
Haitians are different you know you
don't know how how it's going to affect
you the alcohol affects people
differently
roofies affect people differently for us
so I don't think there's any distinctive
difference between it and any of the
other drugs that they use for similar
purpose we can tell my story we went out
to a club Jenny and I one time and I had
maybe two drinks and I got very violent
and very aggressive I started yelling
and I had to be taken out of there
there's only time that ever happened
yeah and I think I drank I think
somebody dosed my drink and they were I
think you were actually the target oh
yeah they got the drinks mixed up yeah
know that how long ago was that um gosh
that was probably six years ago yeah and
we think we know who did it but we're
not going to mention anything yes well
yes that's the thing I thought because I
had never seen you act that way before
and I thought it was just because we've
gone to see a band we got to see then
that I really like and Tom does not care
for them but if you know he went well I
like another song yeah he went with me
to do the trooper but um you know yeah
we didn't have that many drinks because
the drinks were expensive I remember so
we didn't really buy that money and um
and as the show went on he was just
getting the word out of you right angry
getting angry he was yelling at the band
and I when I was in the back I wasn't
even to the front yeah we were some
people were like turning around little
bit was wrong with us and I was getting
really embarrassed yes I gotta get out
of here I got to get out of here and you
know and I was really upset because like
I never had to see that band before and
I remember I was like I remember this
was before we live together
yeah and I remember me getting to your
apartment just going yeah yeah my
[ __ ] car I don't know I don't know
why I got mad and I had never seen you
like that uh before and I never seen you
like that so so I there's no telling
what that was and that drink but it
didn't affect me as intended no no yeah
you just got really I got mad I want to
fly I thought you were having like a
PTSD of yes no what I thought
I kind of thought so at the time too but
now I look back no that's not what that
was yeah yeah that might have been but
yeah later not but um we did you know
this was down toner
Paulo Orlando indocin and in that period
that was happening to a lot of people
yeah mostly girls yes because like I
said I've been dosed um two times the
first time was probably eight years ago
yeah because like I said I would still
marry a t nine years ago and I'll keep
your eyes on your Drent you did yes and
I think I said I didn't know the person
that that dosed me but I think I know
who it was right like because I I knew
like there was a friend of a friend was
like hanging around and all it takes is
one or two bad apples and remember the
cops the cops were investigating a
dosing that happened in the bar next to
our barber yeah we hang out at yeah
remember that they were trying to go
through all the bartenders and try to
figure out who this was yeah and that
bartender over there at that other club
said that it was happening on a regular
basis and that they had a suspect yeah
and you know it does happen I don't
think it doesn't seem like it's um super
common anymore um I know I mean you know
the bar we go to is mostly a cool place
we know pretty lot of people we know
every we know the owner or everybody
that works there and we know most of the
people that hang out there regularly so
we don't worry about it as much but I do
know several girls that have been dosed
there not recently but you know in the
past few years I think the last time I
was dosed there was probably four or
five years ago but it's happened to me
tomorrow when Tori got those that's
right me you and her boyfriend dragged
her out of there and she was uh sitting
she ended up just collapsing and sitting
on the sidewalk everybody's out there
and she's going I'm so sorry I'm so it
doesn't okay big women we had to put it
on all right I just wish I'd all not
have like two or three dress yeah and
like I said the same thing happened to
me I was on my first drink yeah I don't
even it which I need to make I finished
right and I just immediately all I
remember sitting on the bench going wow
I'm really sleepy yeah and then all of a
sudden my hedges women and I just fell
and at that time in the media there was
a lot of stuff about date rape drugs
yeah well they had guys out there some
Lou
years out there thinking that they were
reliable enough to just use the dumb
thing about the time it happened to me
though was that I mean I was clearly
with people yeah you know I was mayor I
was with my ex-husband we were at
another friend of a female friend
everybody we knew that God does was with
somebody yeah it's like why did you
think so obviously as soon as I passed
out you know my husband at the time and
my friend like carried me out to my car
you know and they drove me home so I
don't know what this person was trying
to accomplish I don't know it was just
some loser again I'm kind of like serial
rapist
they don't think reasonably irrationally
tonight I want that woman I'm going to
give I'm going to put this in her drink
and she'll leave with me well that's
kind of an unrealistic expectation well
yeah girl collapses and her friends
carrier out of that know where it
happens and very rarely the girls go out
to bars by themselves there are always
good mostly for that very reason yeah I
mean you know I'm not saying I've gone
to a bar off by myself a couple of times
but usually it's I'm not going to go
unless I know that people I know are
going to be there right and I don't go
to places that I don't that I've never
been to before by myself I would never
[ __ ] do that and right I mean you
know I figured the place we go it's safe
right because I know everybody that is
it takes one lunatic in there with with
delusions of grandeur and some chemicals
in his pocket yeah but this take it back
to the devil's breath I'm guaranteed
that Devil's breath is going to be just
something like like a roof like a roofie
right and like I said you know and
there's nothing bad about that it's just
I don't like this kind of I mean an even
vice kind of overhyped it a little bit
at a time by calling it world fairies
druggin even at the beginning he said
it's like the worst roofie times a
million see that seems a little
hyperbolic it's like a roofie it's
probably a little bit worse than roofie
maybe it's stronger I don't think it
because on how concentrated is how much
dosage you had right how little
resistance you have right I mean I would
think that a person that probably has
never had any contact with any kind of
drug and then they get hit with that
that might be very disturbing so because
they wouldn't recognize what's happened
yeah they wouldn't know it was happening
like I said yeah it's upsetting I mean I
was upset when I was good then you just
pass right out you don't know what the
[ __ ]
a paneer yeah like at the time I got
dosed I didn't know what was going on in
use it I got really mad over a little
things yeah I didn't know they on that
one I was basically five yeah I was like
what the [ __ ] is the matter with them
yeah and it wasn't until it kind of wore
off I was it that wasn't alcohol no I
knew I knew enough to get out of here I
said we got to get out of here oh yeah
get out yeah cuz we left before this
yeah I was only in there for what half
hour it was a little bit louder ah yeah
maybe like an hour yeah and that's not
that's not normal usually mad atcha
to to to cry yeah so yeah that was very
very unusual so I think that was and
like I said I've never seen you act like
that I never acted like that and but
that was interesting if if you happened
oh that's interesting how that affected
you but yeah normally like I said it
would just knock it right out or make
you like really Logan well you know my
metabolism is a little bit different
than other people you know yeah other
than a fight-or-flight response
yeah you might have been like trying to
fight it on water also it was [ __ ] right
you know yeah yeah could you just turned
into like raging
oh yeah psycho yeah which was very scary
yeah and after a few minutes ago I got
to get out of here I gotta get out of
here yeah yeah
so yeah I drove back you did yes I drove
back when I was and I don't know I think
no I drove you drove back yes I remember
when I got I got I had nothing ever
happened yeah because I don't usually
Drive I hate Ronnie no okay so that's
that's got to be what that was we were
just talking about that the other day
yeah when we were get talking about
doing this show yeah but uh actually
we're probably getting toward the end
yeah we didn't really you know we didn't
really like definitively come down he
can do it but nobody like I said I think
a lot of the stories about the
zombification yeah are probably bad
honey it's fun and I think people are
conflating it like I said with surfer
ago because that was exactly the first
thing I thought of they said oh and
they're blowing the pattern people say
stuff like I was representing ago and
turning em into zombies I was like I
think that's where that idea came from
yeah pretty much debunked this whole
thing about just wiping your face with
it smelling and I glow and your face I
don't know the dose will not be enough
that drug dealer himself said that oh
and also it doesn't smell like anything
like the drug itself doesn't have a dish
or an odor the process of refining it
might might quietly about chemical odor
so the this blown it in your face or
wipe in it or smell
it it's not going to be enough all right
this whole thing about being an ultra
passes zombie I guarantee you that that
is going to be a woody college that's
not going to be a reliable that might be
a case-by-case means that other drug
dealers said that his friend it had no
effect on him until they did kept dosing
him and dose him until he died yeah all
right so I mean but she did what they're
describing you something similar to the
other things that they other date rape
drugs yeah it may just be a little more
concentrated yeah I might like XIT
different problems bad enough I don't
think it didn't to worry about right
it's bad enough like a roofie will just
knock you out and people can do whatever
the [ __ ] they want do they just take
your wallet they rape you or whatever
and then just leave you and you don't
remember who did it right you know so
you can't really report it or you don't
remember what happened to you like
that's bad enough
yeah and honestly that's all like if
you're a criminal that's really all you
need you don't really need yeah it'd be
harder to you know go to an ATM if you
want to go to ATM and clean out their
whole bank account but I mean you can
take their wallet you didn't write a
cards you can do all that [ __ ] anyway
when they're unconscious if it wasn't it
as an effective zombie makers they say
intelligence agencies would be using it
of course yeah yes it was like a
reliable mind-control driver yeah it
would be every way we use it as a truth
serum because it's a common planet yeah
it's a common plant they'd be using it
as a truth serum in all different ways
you could use a drug like that and they
don't use that drug yeah they're more
likely to use sodium pentathol on you
yeah because that's more reliable more
reliable how even that is not a reliable
truth thrown there as far as I know I
like I've many years ago I write a book
that which is called mind control and it
was all about those kind of experiments
and they said honestly there isn't one
that's completely reliable one one of
the CIA reports that I heard about this
is one of the most reliable truth terms
is just alcohol you get the guy in a
good mood you have a good time when they
me just getting drunk and he'll start
spilling and he'll just start talking
about it and you want yeah yeah that's
good so you don't really need a drug
Fidel really like I said that's not real
reliably there cuz you don't [ __ ]
know what that you know but you know I
don't think that and actually the book I
write about it they say
kind of said well there isn't one that's
100% reliable you can never know if that
person is telling the truth or if
they're making some stuff up or
exaggerating things because if you don't
have people do and as common as that
drug is in Colombia there would be more
stories yeah and we could actually dig
up yeah you know most of the stories
that we dig it we dug up on this or come
across the board or die's yeah I throw
DN on it right died right or just waking
up and all the resume have gone up and
there they were beat up or you can do
that with any drug yeah that's not me
you can do that pretty much means you
can do that if you gave people and I've
alcohol yeah cuz that makes you sleepy
too yeah so you know I I don't think
it's categorically any different than
anything else she could you know for
nefarious purpose no of that nature no I
wouldn't worry about getting being
turned into a zombie with it now by that
one but still watch your drinks
everybody else watch your drinks for
other [ __ ] not just Coppola me and this
is all kind of crappy will give you foot
in the next UN but you know anyway
that's a we're getting to the end of the
show so we will kind of wrap things up
hopefully it was an in at least an
entertaining show yeah well you know we
didn't want any huge well - oh this is
everything that's going to be our
offshoot channel to entertain your show
don't do drugs kids you're getting you
can if you want but so anyway like I
said project entertainment network on
which our audio podcast is posted they
have a patreon go to the patreon give
them a buck in few bucks whatever and
they'll give you some free [ __ ] also if
you want to buy some t-shirts from us to
have our cool ass logo on them or have
some of our cool show I still like that
real shirt I know love's on get you on
[ __ ] it yeah I didn't want um yeah I'm
going to make them pay maybe now I can
make a Devil's breath t-shirt that would
be awesome
yeah I should have with with the pretty
flower on it the flowers are very pretty
that's why some people have them in
their yards because the area is so
beautiful they look like little bells or
likely a trumpets you never know made
will trump
put a double space on there and blowing
like yeah that's pretty rad was like a
zombie on the other end
I will do anything yeah oh my god I'm
making that shirt okay okay so uh yeah
so if you want to see shirt go to
zazzle.com last 13 o'clock and there's
five different shirts there and also if
you liked our show subscribe to our
youtube channel or go to our facebook
page or twitter which are both 13
o'clock podcasts and go give us your
like or give us a follower what have you
podcast is doing good YouTube shows
going doing good we're almost at 200
viewers or 200 subs what a podcast doing
good yeah yeah it depends on the subject
right now we just like I think I
mentioned another show last week we just
kind of do subjects that we kind of pull
out of our asses under category I got it
so you know some people like them some
people all like them whatever it is
that's in the other day they want
somebody asked for a show on Crowley we
should do one that's a good idea
I think we also wanted to be one of the
skull experiments as well that I was
talking about and we have a guest that
wants to come off oh right I forgot they
did an episode on paranormal witness
with this person yeah okay and this
person has not really spoken publicly or
done a public show since the paranormal
witness show came out and it's one of
our favorite episodes episode yes that
was a good episode yeah I'm not naming
names but that person that was knows who
they are they are also subscriber okay
okay
yeah so we might be to hope to have you
on in a couple weeks yeah that will be
good
so that'll do it for episode 22 the
devil's press yes whoo and see you guys
next Tuesday bye bye
you
[Music]